you made similar promises in 2010 you
lied immigration laws how can we believe
in alpha well let me let me ask that
very directly I made the promise and
outside the EU we did get immigration
down inside the EU partly because the
rest of the US economy has not performed
and we've created more jobs than the
rest of the EU put together it's been
very difficult to meet that target I now
need to make these benefit changes these
welfare changes the things I've just
described and I need to negotiate those
in Europe now I would argue I've got a
track record of that I cut the European
budget first Prime Minister ever to do
it I veto to European treaty because it
wasn't in our national interest I've
kept Britain out of the euro I can
deliver these things in Europe but I
need your mandate sir in seven days time
to get out there and win a good deal for
Britain that controls immigration and
gets us a better position in Europe and
with me you'll get that enact referendum
you the British people deciding before
the end of 2017 maybe